the potential negative aspect is that
you can have people concealing their
identity in order to troll or even not
people bots
so how do you know in the metaverse that
you're talking to
a real human or an ai or a
well-intentioned human is that something
you think about something you're
concerned about
well
let's break that down into a few
different cases i mean because knowing
that you're talking to someone who has
good intentions is something that i
think is not even solved in right in
pretty much anywhere but
i mean if you're talking to someone
who's a dragon i think it's pretty clear
that they're not representing themselves
as a person i think probably the most
pernicious thing that you want to
solve for
is um
i think probably one of the scariest
ones is how do you make sure that
someone isn't impersonating you
right so
like okay you're in a future version of
of this conversation yeah and we have
photorealistic avatars and we're doing
this in work rooms or whatever the
future version of that is and someone
walks in who like looks like me um how
do you know that that's me and
one of the things that we're that we're
thinking about is you know it's this
it's still a pretty big ai project to be
able to generate photorealistic avatars
that basically can like they work like
these codecs of you right so you kind of
have a map from your your headset and
whatever sensors what your body's
actually doing and it takes the model in
it and it kind of displays it in vr but
there's a question which is should there
be some sort of biometric security so
that like when i put on my vr headset or
i'm going to you know go use that avatar
i need to first prove that i am that and
i think you probably are gonna want
something like that so um so that's you
know as we're developing these
technologies we're also thinking about
the security for things like that um
because
people aren't gonna want to be
impersonated that's a that's a huge
security issue um
then you just get the question of people
hiding behind
fake accounts to do malicious things
which is not going to be unique to the
metaverse although
you know certainly
in a
environment where it's more immersive
and you have more of a sense of presence
it could be more
painful more painful
but this is obviously something that
we've just dealt with for
years um in social media and the
internet more broadly and there i think
um
there have been a bunch of tactics that
that i think um
we've just evolved to you know we've
built up these
different ai systems to basically get a
sense of is this
account
behaving in the way that a person would
and
it turns out you know so in all of the
work that we've done um
around you know we call it community
integrity and it's basically like
policing
harmful content and trying to figure out
where to draw the line and there are all
these like really hard and philosophical
questions around like where do you draw
the line on some of this stuff and
the the thing that that i i've kind of
found the most effective
is as much as possible trying to figure
out who are the
inauthentic accounts or where the
accounts that are behaving in an overall
harmful way at the account level
rather than trying to get into like
policing what they're saying right which
i think the metaverse is going to be
even harder
um because that the metaverse i think
will have more properties of
um it's almost more like a phone call
right or like or you're you know it's
not like i post a piece of content and
is that piece of content good or bad
um so i think more of this stuff will
have to be done at the level of
um of the account but
this is the area where you know between
the
the kind of
um
you know counterintelligence teams that
we built up inside the company and like
years of building um just different ai
systems to basically detect what is a
real account and what isn't i'm not
saying we're perfect but like this is an
area where i just think we are like
years ahead of basically anyone else in
the in the industry in terms of having
um
uh built those capabilities and i think
that that just is going to be incredibly
important for this next wave of things
and like you said on the technical level
on a philosophical level it's an
incredibly difficult problem to
solve uh by the way i i would probably
like to open source my avatar so there
could be like millions of lexus walking
around just like an army like agent
smith agent smith yeah exactly
uh so the uh
the unity ml folks built a copy of me
and they sent it to me
so there's a there's a person running
around and i just been doing
reinforcement learning on it i was gonna
release it
now
because you know just to have sort of
like uh thousands of lexus doing uh
reinforcements so they fall over
naturally they have to learn how to like
walk around and stuff so i love that
idea this tension between biometric
security you want to have one identity
but then certain avatars you might have
to have many um i don't know which is
better security sort of flooding the
world with lexus and thereby achieving
security or really being protective of
your identity i i have to ask a security
question actually how does flooding the
world with lexus help me know in our
conversation that i'm talking to the
real ex i completely destroy the trust
in all my relationships then right if i
flood because then
it's yeah that um
i think that one's not going to work
that well for you it's not going to work
that way i mean for the original
it probably fits some things like if
you're a public figure and you're trying
to
have
you know a bunch of
if you're trying to show up in a bunch
of different places in the future you'll
be able to do that in the metaverse um
so that kind of replication i think will
be useful but i do think you're gonna
want a notion of like
i am talking to the real one
yeah
yeah especially if the if the fake ones
start out performing you and all your
private relationships
and then you're left behind i mean
that's that's a serious concern i have
with clones again
the things i think about
you